Tomorrow we are the 20/03
and will take place the spring equinox.
Here are 5 things you can do
to be able to celebrate and to be able to
use the energy of the equinox properly.
For those who do not know
the spring equinox,
it is simply 1 astronomical event.
It occurs
when the plane of the equator
earth passes through the center
of the sun.
The opposite of the equinox,
it's the solstice and you have
certainly must have heard it when talking about the solstice
winter.
The first thing you will be able to
do for tomorrow's equinox,
is to do 1 meditation in the open air.
I am currently in Colombia
so I don't have the French crown,
but I could only see that
was beginning to be
1 little warmer in terms of temperature.
So take the opportunity to go meditate outdoors.
The purpose of this meditation,
is to connect deeply
to the coming energies of spring.
The second thing you can do,
it is 1 ritual of purification.
You will be able to purify your environment
physical and spiritual.
For this,
you will be able to use sage,
from Palo Santo,
incense,
essential oil,
It works very well too.
To do 1 purification of your physical body,
you will simply take 1 bath
or 1 shower with coarse salt
and you will rub yourself everywhere
and you will put 1 intention of purification,
this is the most important thing.
And most importantly,
remember to well because the salt,
it can a little bit.
If you feel connected to hotel design,
you will be able to create your spring hotel.
So you're going to get some little flowers,
things that remind you of spring
and connect you
directly with the energy of this Equinox.
There are no real rules,
you can take
feathers that you found on the ground,
leaves that remind you of spring,
small flowers,
of the grass.
You win.
By creating this hotel,
you will bring 1 renewal energy,
of spring,
of flowering
and you will be able to use it for the
upcoming events
or to be able to do the 4th thing
that I will tell you
right away.
The 4th thing you can do tomorrow,
at the equinox,
it will be to practice the
gratitude in full consciousness.
1 tip,
don't keep your
gratitude in your thought and in your brain,
which means that they will have to be published in writing,
or aloud
if you don't feel comfortable talking
all alone.
1 tip,
write your gratitude.
Take a look at the beginning of your year,
what are the things that make you happy,
who are the people who make you happy.
Write or say out loud
everything you are
grateful to you deep down.
And 5th and final thing,
you will be able to do 1 meditative walk
in full consciousness.
So it's not the same,
you.
Go for a walk in the wild,
preferably
preferably alone,
it will allow you to meditate and to
refocus on yourself,
of power
also observe the small signs of renewal.
So pay attention to
animals you will meet,
pay attention to
all the signs of the universe that are sent to you
during this meditative walk.
I don't know about you,
but I'm so happy when spring
is coming! In France,
this is 1 of my favorite seasons.
What's your favorite season?